High quality lenses can be used to improve clarity for
the eye or for a camera, the brain cannot influence
this area. Too much light can temporarily or permanently blind
eyes but will also blind a typical camera as the
image produced will be overexposed often appearing all white. It's
the eye that's damaged, not the brain's interpretation of what
the eye is seeing. Muscles in the eye control the
eye's focus but the brain does not interpret the image differently.
The answer is that we see images right side up.
Look at our pinhole camera model. The image is actually formed
upside down. The simple idea that the image on a retina
goes directly into our brain in that form is clearly false.
There is in fact a considerable amount of processing that
occurs in the brain beyond just rotating the image 180 degrees.
For example, our eyes have blind spots where the optic nerve
is attached. Our brains fill in this area with the surrounding
elements in the scene.